thank you
hey everybody and welcome to a frosty
wild ride with Stephen we've got the
king of snowboarding Sean White he is a
cold killer when it comes to competition
and man what a life he's LED all these
Olympic medals the skull fractures being
on tour with Bam Margera as a kid and
not saying that Tony Hawk felt bad for
him man is that crazy this one's juicy
folks so strap on and let's get into it
I just thought the minivan from my
backyard oh nice what size what are we
talking it's it's like three and a half
feet 16 feet wide okay nice it's super
mellow transitions it's just fun 16 is
good you want enough to like lock into a
grind because otherwise you're like you
know you can't really feel that you know
getting the Smith grind and then you run
out of real estate right then we should
have Sean come to the skate party yeah
time for sure all right dude we'll dive
right into it here we go ladies and
gentlemen Sean White hello yes
we got the white Wild Ride sign here we
go
man I I uh I'm pleasantly surprised
thrilled that we got you on here yeah
right on we uh really do pride ourselves
on the most
high standards of action sports
people you know like in skateboarding
we've had Tony Hawk nigah Houston
Sheckler Brian Sheckler
Danny way and I think that's it okay
yeah I'm in the mix
yeah Rob Dyrdek oh yeah
yes in any case like whatever we don't
have to you know honk our own horn too
much but uh but yeah whether it's crazy
like icon you know like uh it
there's not even
this is not even another name anybody
could name of a snowboarder I think in
in a household sense so yeah it's pretty
wild man there's just so much to talk
about of course you've got a four-part
docu-series on HBO Max it's just called
Max now just max now yeah and before we
jump I was gonna say you know like I I
mean you're throwing those names I mean
when I was asked to do this the show I
was like oh hell yeah because we'd
bumped into each other a few times and
like man you know your your
entertainment you put out for years and
and you know my childhood hanging with
bam and all this guy I mean yeah it was
like I was like oh this is great yeah
I'd love to be a part of this so yeah
yeah wasn't it
um an audio Shoes video that you and
Tony Hawk had a double part and Bam had
a part in the same video yeah yeah well
we would go on tour together in like the
bus and it was Rowdy I mean if we talked
about the docu-series on Max
um called the last run but there's
footage of that tour in there where like
those guys
definitely like broke me into the
skateboarding like they're like it ain't
gonna be easy we're gonna you know The
Hazing the like in a fun way but it was
it was you know a rowdy rowdy tour I
can't imagine Tony Hawk gets rowdy
you know at the time
um you know he had kind of the weight of
the world on his shoulders because he
was like carrying the tour you know he
was his name's on the bus he's got the
game coming out you know there's a lot
of pressure but before the game no I
couldn't have been no but you know game
numbers what year was that three or
whatever at this point I'm trying to
remember I know it was a rarity and I
was three yeah it was like a 102. yeah
because my mom let me go solo and that
was a big deal and she's like why trust
Tony Hawk he's got a kid so he's not
gonna like you know she had trust so I
was probably like
I gotta say like 13 or 14 right yeah and
it was like
um
you know
just watching you know those skaters go
town to town and just tear it up and
like not only the skating was insane but
just like they would go out at night you
know I'm getting a glimpse of like this
kind of like rock and roll sort of tour
lifestyle at a young age going wow this
is this is and because it's snowboarders
I feel like we're a bit more buttoned up
but yeah it was it was like okay wow
this was super fun
um but yeah that was a wild time for
sure I think that you're skateboarding
is criminally overlooked and in a lot of
sense because I remember that audio
video yeah and he was like like was that
like your
I mean it's certainly your introduction
to me it was the first time I heard
about you you were doing I remember 720s
for sure like uh you won a couple gold
uh X Games right yeah I mean I remember
Tony being pissed because I learned a
720 before 5 40. he's like it's not how
you got it's not how you do it you gotta
start here you gotta you know like it
just worked better and do I remember it
was like a method 720 that made it
different like yeah yeah I would I
because of snowboarding I knew spins in
big errors and stuff like that because
the path's like 22 feet tall we bump it
down to like a 13-foot vert ramp you're
like oh my God this is Tiny it feels
tiny right and so you get you know
um me being comfortable in the air and
so I always said that like my
snowboarding brought my skateboarding
the size and and just the the magnitude
of it you know big jump so we hit a jump
on a skateboard it's maybe like oh it's
like a 12 foot Gap you know snowboard's
like a 90-foot job huge you know right
yeah an Arctic blizzard you know and
then and then I feel like skateboarding
brought my snowboarding like the
technical aspect like the Precision
Because by the time I got to snow I'm
like oh my God the board just gonna stay
on my feet
what could be easier if you fall you're
falling on snow well that was
it sounds comfy but it's not it's I mean
it's it's icy yeah those walls and
conditions can get pretty brutal or it
can rain the night before and it just
turns into this Frozen like oh it's it's
rough so you found snowboarding a little
bit more easy to progress in I found it
yeah I found it easier for yeah from my
My overall sort of like I just took to
it right away it was easier but
skateboarding was always that kind of
unsung thing and I'm I'm glad you
mentioned that my skate career kind of
got overlooked because that was really
hard in the documentary because we were
trying to balance like well how much
skate how much snow and and I was like
man you guys are really we're harping
really hard on the Olympics in this in
the snow stuff but there were like a
solid nine years there where I would
hang up the snowboard and go be the top
three at every single skate competition
for you know that period of time that
was a big chunk of time and and now I
see people on Instagram who was it uh it
was Tony or uh Andy Mack posted
something he's like this was like one of
the heydays of vert skating it was a
clip of me winning one of the due tour
events and the comment below is like
dude it's got the same name as that
snowboard guy that's so weird
you're like no dude that's me
but uh yeah it was a yeah it's a good
time and and uh was it always vert
skating or like when you were on the uh
like the boom boom hug Jam Tony Hawk
tour were you hitting the street course
I would a little bit I got a funny story
of when I skated street because when I
my first introduction was to ramps like
I had a YMCA nearby that Tony would
frequent the Encinitas yeah it was a
legendary place and so I just got
introduced to that right away and Street
skating wasn't really
as exciting it seemed you know more
redundant and Technical and like
repetitive like I'm just gonna try this
kickflip in the street over and over and
over where the ramps I'm like oh man I
can launch something I can grind and
there's just like a whole park
designated for it and so I really took
to that and then my buddies are like
come skate street with us I'm like sure
at this point I used pads my whole life
so I uh in a and we show up
we show up to the street spot it's like
a four or five stair drop and all I
remember is going okay cool I like I
Ollie this thing or try to kickflip this
thing and I'm not gonna make it so
instinctually like instinctively I go
into a knee slide I jumped a five foot
onto my knees probably in shorts and
everyone looked at me like oh my God why
why would you do that why I'm just like
knees are bleeding I'm like I'm just
gonna go home
you know it's just embedded in my brain
to knee slide um in a panic situation so
that kind of ended my street career
pretty quickly yeah that's crazy man
um with uh
with
action sports like
it's I mean it's shared but I'm trying
to articulate this I feel like the the
level of danger is just at a point
where people are dying like all over
like we're like we're losing people from
the Nitro Circus camp like on an
alarmingly regular basis it feels like
and
um
you know there's
like I I've posted uh clips of like
parkour kids and they're up on like
buildings oh my God jump up on buildings
they're like just jumping from doing a
flip from one building to the next
building they're like hanging from their
fingertips yeah and all the comments
when I post that is like dude these
people are stupid they're like it's
gonna be they're gonna die like this is
just totally idiotic I can't believe it
like yeah but then
the guy who's climbing up El Capitan
with no ropes wins an Oscar yeah you
know like yeah yeah so there's like
there's this disconnect where like some
people are taking risks and it's frowned
upon but then like in the Olympics was
it was it 2010 that they increased the
size of the half pipe from like 18 feet
to 22 feet or something exactly yeah
like and then at that size like and and
with the sponsors like in order to be
sponsored in order to like win anything
like you have to take these risks like
it just
do you feel like there's a point at
which we got to be like hey like step in
here and you know or what like I don't
know I mean it's really hard to say just
because I think
you know with anything there's always a
progression like F1 the cars are getting
faster right they're doing you know but
they're like hey like let's make sure
everybody's wearing the you know the
flame resistant suits we gotta get the
helmets right we gotta get there are
safety regulations like when I started
helmets were very frowned upon
I can remember a time when it was also
frowned upon to have a little bit of
help in the bedroom but not anymore baby
now it's just considered a good time to
take a Bluetooth tablet and enjoy that
help in the bedroom what's so helpful
about it well Bluetooth tablets have the
same active ingredient as both Viagra
and Cialis but they only cost a fraction
of the price and get this the listeners
of the Wild Ride podcast can get an
entire month's supply of Bluetooth
tablets completely for free and only pay
five bucks for shipping now why would
you do this because it really is a good
old time man my relationship with Lux
thrives on Bluetooth and I'm not ashamed
to admit that I don't think anybody even
frowns upon it you sort out your
prescription super fast with the online
medical provider on the website takes no
time at all and boom you've got an
entire month's supply of Bluetooth
tablets on the way just make sure that
you use that promo code Stevo to do this
and find out how much fun it is
bluetooth.com with the promo code Stevo
and all you pay is five bucks for
shipping jump on this deal have fun let
me know how it goes and let's get back
to it
right it was like you're a joke if you
show up with a helmet on and major
sponsors of mine are like you gotta get
rid of the house snowboarding or
skateboarding uh snowboarding and um and
they're just like you'll never be in a
magazine you'll never be in a video and
now like you have to show up they check
your helmet at the competition to make
sure it's up to standard for competing
like it's a mandatory thing so like
things are changing and you know the 22
foot half pipe that was a big one in a
way that I thought it actually made it a
little bit safer just because
um you know think about an airplane you
got this big airplane and it's landing
on this little Runway you know the
margin for error is pretty pretty slim
where if you get a bigger Runway I can
throw bigger tricks and bigger you know
errors but I have more to land on I have
more to catch more so in a way it got
more advanced and a little more
dangerous because we're going faster
we're going bigger but then again
there's more to catch you and then with
the invention of the airbags and the
foam pits that stuff really helped
progress the sport but yeah I think it's
like an ebb and flow of you know us
pushing the limits and then technology
kind of catching up or something in the
sport changing
um but I don't know I always look at it
like probably driving to the mountain
was
car accidents like it's probably more
dangerous to drive to the mountains you
know than you know what I mean you think
about the risks that we take every
single day just crossing the street
these things that happen that you don't
hear about you know what I mean so so I
don't know it's like it's a weird
balance of it but definitely watching
the sport now and watching the crashes
and things like I feel and especially
after watching my my own you know
documentary series I was just like wow
like I got out
and I and I'm in one piece so that was
that was great right what was that
gnarly injury like I didn't get that far
in I had a few
um there was there's one that really
kind of shook me my family and the
community that we lived in was I crashed
with Bob bernquest and that was really
bad
that was no I I was 11 years old it was
an MTV Sports and music festival were
you there I don't know okay this is way
back I think Jamie Foxx was hosting he
showed up with an afro and these huge
socks and was like skateboarding like a
little dart board like a banana board
around the vert ramp chasing me there's
like some funny footage that we found
digging through the archive but I was
doing a doubles routine with Bob and we
collided mid session and and I was a lot
it was a one-sided fist fight I mean he
clobbered me and so I broke my hand I
broke my foot and I fractured my skull
and then I you know I get home and I
cruise into school and teacher just
looks at me starts crying everybody's
like you know it was a really it was a
really heavy thing that happened and
what was crazy about it was the reaction
of the community we lived in because
they're like oh
you guys got what you deserved you're
doing these sports that we don't
understand and look what happened to
your son like this was a matter of time
before this happened not like because we
knew we don't normally do doubles you
don't normally do these things it's not
like I tried some big trick and took
this crash it was like an accident but
you know the school tightened up on me
like leaving to go on you know trips for
competition everything kind of got weird
and then you know as a family like what
do you do when you're my your mom and
dad and you're like God everybody's
looking at us like those terrible
parents that now being that young and
taking a slam like that yeah do your
parents take a step back and maybe
reconsider like letting you go forward
into chasing this dream of snowboarding
yes so I don't want to give away too
much of the dog but there's this
beautiful interview with my mom where
she's she's talking about he's like so
what do we do now what's next she's like
well I just got to get him back on the
ramp and they're like what that's
awesome and and you go you know okay if
your kid was in a car accident it you're
not like let's just get them behind the
wheel we got to get them back in there
you know yeah yeah it's holiday good
night what are you talking about you
know so she really was there to be like
I know he loves it because I did I would
cry if I couldn't go to the skate park
after school was My Punishment like if
you don't do the dishes you can't go
skate tomorrow and I'm like scrubbing
all the dishes you know so I just truly
loved it and and so she knew that if I
you know had this you got to get back on
the horse and if if this one incident
like you know kept me from a a career in
a lifetime love of this Sport and
friendships and this like everything I
was gonna get from it she didn't want to
prevent that so she actually like helped
guide me back into skateboarding I
remember the day I was I was at the
skate park and I because I I after the
crash you know the cast finally came off
I was like I don't know I just didn't
want to skate anymore I was over it and
she finally convinced me to go to the
skate park and I skated up to the fence
and I was like I'm over it like I don't
ever I don't want to do this anymore I
want to quit she's like all right well
I paid five dollars for you to do this
session so you're gonna finish the
session and I was like you know what I
mean like just such a mom comment yeah
well I paid five bucks so you're staying
I was like fine I remember running over
to the vert ramp I was killing some time
and I bumped into Kevin's knob
um you know renowned skateboarder
legendary guy you can spot his hair from
a mile away
um and he taught me basically backside
airs that day I could only do front side
airs and I you know what I mean that
feeling of learning a new trick I was
just like I was hooked all over again
and so that's what got me back into
skating but um but yeah those injuries
are something that's like it's a hard
thing to bounce back from and a hard
thing to get not only your physical but
like your mental straight especially a
fresher skull yeah that was rough and
what happened was the you know when when
I fracture my skull the blood had pulled
on my forehead and what's called the
hematoma and like and then all the blood
settled in my eyes and so I just had
these crazy black eyes oh yeah I look
like I cast on my arm and my leg I like
hobbling into class and they just looked
at me like what happened when Kevin stop
teaches you a backside air is it like an
early grab or a leg grab situation
I think it was late grab because I could
already
um you know I I envied another kid that
skated at the park
um gosh what was his name I think Steve
something
um he was a bit older than me and he was
the sweetest guy ever super super nice
and but he skated for birdhouse and I
was like I hate this guy like he's gotta
go you know what I mean I just created
this like
you know I don't want to say enemy but
like someone to rival with because he I
wanted to be friends with Tony he was
already on birdhouse I was like but I
remember the way that he all he would
Ollie before he yeah got to the top of
it rant but I hit the coping with my
wheels and so that's how I kind of
figured that I could maybe start going
higher than him because I'm already
starting at a at a at a you know a
different way I guess you could say but
yeah I remember learning it that day
and just like that feeling and and then
it just opened up this whole new world
of tricks for me and and then it just
kind of like went from there yeah yeah
when did the airbags come in to the
snowboarding and was that all you I seem
to think it was all you pretty much most
of it was inspired see I was I was
learning new tricks just you could
basically show up and be all right
today's the day I'm gonna go for this
thing I'm gonna I'm gonna wing it
um and what happened was a lot of guys
in the back country started doing these
double flips and they're doing double
flips because in the backcountry it's
deep snow it's powder it's a natural
airbag they can just chuck whatever you
know make mistakes but then it's all
good and so there's no real way to
replicate that in the half pipe so I
started kind of thinking about it and I
had gone to one of those Woodward camps
um where they had the big foam pits for
the gymnastics and then I saw Pastrana
trying his double backflips into the
foam pad why the technology exists why
don't we tap into this and I can learn
some tricks and and so I link together
with the sponsor and we created this
half pipe setup with the foam pit and it
was supposed to be this big secret and
then it just became this very well-known
secret that I was doing it and so my
competitors in in a rush to keep up with
me were like they called their sponsors
and they're like we can't I mean we
gotta buy foam and ship it out and build
a container for it and all these things
and they're like well why don't we do
this airbag thing and so that kind of
started the airbag Trend and I was a
little annoyed I was like why didn't I
think of there it's like way easier the
blocks were all getting you know snowed
on and then freezing overnight like it
wasn't it wasn't uh your competitors did
the airbags yeah to combat what I was
doing and I was like dang I didn't even
think of the airbag that's way easier
you know and so but that's how it all
started you know and when that was
around 2006 for that excuse me 2010 for
the Vancouver Vancouver right okay that
was uh
dude that's crazy man and that that
could make so much sense that the foam
is gonna freeze oh yeah it'd get wet it
would freeze you're losing your goggles
and then the worst part is is that you
know when you go into a foam pit it's
not a pleasant feeling and when you have
a board on your feet like you're stuck I
couldn't get to my feet so the first
jump I go in and that that awful feeling
of like you're suffocating like the
goggles are over my face and I'm just
claustrophobic in the bottom of the pit
like
and everybody's sitting there watching
for good 15 like oh he can't get out
so then at a certain point Adam my dad
was just like lifeguard he would just
like come unstrap me and pull me out but
I became more nervous of the airbag than
actually excuse me the foam pit of you
know how I was gonna end up in it but
it's not foolproof I ended up uh when I
was learning the double MC twist I
landed in the foam and the way the foam
works is it's it's like you know uh it
kicks back it's springy and so as I
landed in it I I compressed and then it
started to push back and I my momentum
still carrying me forward so I felt this
like in my ankle and so I chipped a
piece of bone
um Landing in the foam pit and that's
what ended that whole session I was like
oh I can't I can't ride anymore it ended
the session yeah yeah yeah yeah exactly
and that's so Danny Way yes yeah
um yeah yeah like how many surgeries are
have you done like ACLS and all that
stuff man so I really kind of pride
myself that my career was really built
off me landing on my feet I've watched
some docs and talked to any of these
guys and like man I've had
like I had the bad accident when I was a
kid so it was a broken hand foot and
then the skull and it's not really a
joint yeah that's not like a thing and
so I think it wasn't until I was 16 I
had a small tear and the lateral side of
my meniscus which is the padding in
between
um right in your knee that keeps you
kind of is that what happened Isaac
meniscus
um I think so yeah out of all the knee
injuries that's the less well that's
that's the one you want because it's
like they can come in they clean it up
and they're good to go where the other
ones you either have to reattach a
ligament or tendon or you have to get a
cadaver right you know I hope it takes
yeah Isaac got the cadaver it's an ACL
yeah so that one luckily I didn't have
to deal with and then I I like I like
ripped a ligament my thumb uh a lot of
concussions unfortunately and then um
and then the big crash in New Zealand
where I kind of ripped my face open
which really sucked that one was brutal
but that was kind of it they owned the
chip bone in the ankle that was about it
for the for a whole career doing this
that was pretty great yeah that's epic
dude yeah I felt very fortunate because
you know there are yeah you know you
talk to anybody that rides Motocross or
football players like oh I just
shattered this or this exploded and
you're like oh yeah I was talking to an
ex-nfl football player yesterday yeah
and I told him that I've never had any
knee surgery and he was like his head
exploded like he's like what really yeah
man like uh been very very lucky with
with joints and I mean I had my ankle
screwed together with the compound but
actually it's so funny what was that
yeah the collarbone yeah golden knees
but just glass ankles yeah right I think
a lot of us are strong in some areas and
weak in others and if you're weak area
involves a smelly stinky terrible habit
that you want to drop the good news is
fume baby what's a fume it's a diffusive
device which helps you replace bad
habits with good habits this diffusive
device it flavors air I have it in my
pocket all the time because I just love
the flavored air with the core in there
that flavors the air
you want to replace
dangerous chemicals and addictive drugs
with flavored air it's a healthy move
and you know you got to drop that nasty
habit so go to trifum.com
and use the promo code Stevo to get 10
off your journey pack why is it called a
journey pack because it's your journey
to a healthier happier and less ashamed
you
don't do it with the bad habit anymore
man drop the shame pick up the fume by
going to trifum.com and using the promo
code Stevo for 10 off your journey pack
I always have it in my pocket you can
ask me and I will if I don't I'll make a
shout out video for you try seeing baby
try fume.com now let's get back to it
yeah I was uh we'll never dance I I
shattered my ankle with uh Danny where I
was I was trying to do a boneless off of
a wooden porta potty like while Danny
Wade crashed a car through I think I've
seen footage of this yeah so Danny
Wade's crashing the car through it Tony
Hawk's over here shooting it on his
phone yeah yeah I want to stick this
thing so bad because we've already like
crashed three porta potties and we're on
the last one yeah and I'm not even on
the board but in my head I'm like I'm
just gonna stick it yeah yeah yeah and
I'm just trying to stick it and shatter
my ankle my foot's coming out sideways
yeah and uh you know Danny's there he's
like dude gotta bring you to my surgeon
yeah yeah Danny's got his surgeon she's
calling him up
doctor previte yeah no I I I'm
definitely was like your key demo at
that time for those videos I was like
all right let's go you know but I always
remember
not to knock it in any way but I always
remember having to
it was always a thing I was always
struggling to keep my sport in a place
of like athleticism and this is a this
is a career path for other kids and like
because it was hard for me to get
through school to do these things and so
when the jackass movement happened and
all those things like obviously there
was skateboarding in it but somehow it
kind of got wrapped up into like oh this
is what you do as well and I'm like no
no no it's a lot different you know what
I mean and and I remember at times being
frustrated because I wanted to
legitimize my sport as much as I could
right and it was hard to hard at the
time because the video releases would
come out and you guys would be doing
some wild stuff and they're like why
can't you come on the talk show and do
those things as well oh wow I heard you
saying that it was tough you know if we
wonder where your goggles on stage and
we're gonna slide you in yeah so like
but I would do fun things like I'm game
I'm not a stiff I'd be like yeah like if
it's for this cool it's good do that
like we did like a slime Rodeo out and
wherever it would say the folks and like
we did some stuff and I was all for it
and I was like hyped you guys were
crushing it but I remember at the time
like after my first Olympics it was
rough they're like so cool like we're
gonna like get we're gonna get the stage
hands with a bunch of buckets of snow
we're gonna slide you on stage we're
gonna throw the snow at you and then you
sit down and pop your goggles off open
up a Mountain Dew and and say this I was
like what
I'm an Olympian yeah totally and I was
just like oh man it's like I had to
start saying no I was like no I won't do
that and you're begging to be on you
know as a athlete you want a certain
level of success or at least I did badly
to be accepted and to be you know
finally on one of these shows and to win
an SB or do those things so and then it
was like kind of soured by hey what
stunt can you do and so finally you know
I just kept saying no no no and then
finally somebody's like okay
come on I was like all right let's try
like wore a suit I walked on I played
the video I was I was you know whatever
cordial I was you know made the jokes it
was great and then that set the tempo
for how you see me you know which is
interesting because I like I love Tony
he's the man you know but whenever you
see him he's holding a skateboard yeah
it's it's Inseparable I think he's got a
thing where he likes that he's like well
I've got a thing where I've skateboarded
on every stage in the world or something
like he's got like a tally going like he
wanted to skateboard out at the Oscars
this last go or maybe not the last but
the one before oh yeah but he was all
messed up yeah he's all messed up he was
a hurt but anyways I was like oh I don't
know if I want to be you know you learn
a lot from watching I was like gosh I
don't want to be the guy that has to
like carry my snowboard out on stage at
the right time you know and so a lot of
that kind of thing yeah clicked in my
head when I was younger of like wow this
is that moment where you have to kind of
decide where you're going to be and and
I was representing a much bigger group
than myself because you're like no
you're the snowboarder so whatever you
say at this point goes that was the most
like how old are you guys
19. yeah so that's a kind of a weird
thing to go through at 19 because
you know like
yeah I grew up really quick I mean a lot
of my friends at 19 were just like being
punks having fun you know what I mean
and it was like oh no I should put the
suit on and go like represent my sport
on television you know yeah so it was
weird it seems like that was a good call
on your part because I remember walking
through Target and seeing like all the
Sean white line of stuff and like it
wasn't you holding a snowboard like it
was like legitimately just Sean White
like just your name and your your person
and you weren't like
um kind of pigeonholed into like
something where you know so it seems
like a smart move yeah and I it's not
like I wanted and I woke up one day like
oh this is what's up and this is how I
have to conduct myself in business and
these things but it just kind of
happened over time where I was signing
autographs at one of the X Games and I
rode for a beverage company and I
remember getting the poster I looked
horrible I'm like cold my face is red or
what you know what I mean it's just like
a terrible image but the but the product
looked like you could just grab it off
the page you know and just drink that
baby like the the you know
um condensation on the on the can uh and
I remember thinking to myself like God
like
how can I can I get approval over these
things can I at least weigh in or
whatever and I remember talking to my
agent at the time and I was like he's
like oh you want the right of approval
of your ads and things like yeah I want
that I want to be involved I wanna and
that just started like well now that I'm
involved and we won't sign a deal now
unless I have this then now going
forward and then I got swept into like
well how am I portrayed and how am I so
when you went into Target and saw those
signs and Those ads I had gone through
countless photos and we picked the one
that was like oh this best represents me
the product looks great man and and what
was cool about it is like
you know it's a tough sport it's like
you're a sellout you're a yeah he's not
core anymore or whatever and like I was
like well look like
man like I shopped at Target my parents
like we didn't have a ton of cash
there's like affordable stuff and we'd
go to Target and we buy the stuff and so
when we were there it was like oh this
makes so much sense and it wasn't like I
was wearing Target clothes it was like
my design stuff at Target that's cool so
it was always kind of like a couple
layers of
you know thought that went into it
before doing something like that but
yeah I only buy clothes at Target yeah
and and it's so interesting when you say
that because it
it's not even about if your core or if
you're it's just about like if you're
successful people are gonna hate on you
mm-hmm yeah it's really that simple it
was a hard pill to swallow when you're
young too because you're like wow they
just don't dig me because of this or
like there's this you know sort of image
going around that people are saying this
and how do you combat that and and I
feel like at that age you just want to
be accepted by everybody oh for sure and
think of this I mean at that point I'd
I'd only known life traveling in a van
with my parents from competition to
competition and so I went pro at 13 all
my competitors are like mid to Upper 20s
so I'm like yeah I'm like trying to talk
to them explain Pokemon to them while
they're playing quarters
okay this isn't good there's a miss here
um and uh you know and so I finally go
pro and like I'm just kind of like the
kid on tour and then finally by the time
I'm
I reached a certain age my competitors
and I were butting heads because we're
competing against each other you know
and then uh I think Tony said something
once that kind of tripped me out he's
like yeah he's kind of felt bad for Sean
I was like what and he's like yeah
because he
he never really belonged in the Skate
World because of the snowboarding stuff
and you know and he had a hard time
fitting into the snowboarding world
because he was so young and that you
know he was just like and I I never
really thought about it until he said
that I was like oh wow you know struck
like a weird cord from my childhood I
was like oh yeah he's right like you
know so it was a weird sort of you know
dance to be in and I never lived in the
mountains so I was my whole career I
grew up at the beach yeah I had asthma I
hated the cold and so like when we found
snowboarding I was like oh this is cool
I didn't realize he had to go to like
Norway and Sweden you know I feel like
that was a good business move because
like isn't there like a curse for
Olympians that like once they hit the
Olympics there's not really a lot of
places for them to go after and after so
like were you aware of that and it's
like strike while the iron's hot yes and
no I know I remember that the Olympics
wasn't an option and then all of a
sudden around 15 or just before I was 15
I was Nagano they had
um for the first time ever snowboarding
and it was more of like an exhibition
than uh yeah is that 2006 no that was
two before that so 2002 was Utah uh the
Salt Lake City games and so is the one
before that in Japan okay and so um
so we watched on TV I was like wow this
is crazy and then when it kind of became
an option for me they had a thing that
said that if you'd made the Olympic team
the Olympic team would cover like
um I forget what it was like six years
of college tuition oh cool so that was
like a real like well hey if I could
just make the team I got a backup plan
yeah master's degree yeah you could go
you could go you know and they'd pay
your way and I was like oh this could be
cool okay so at least there's that going
um but I already really knew what I
wanted to do and I had success in the
sport but um
but yeah it was like it was an
interesting time
um but I I think I don't know if it's as
much as a curse is just like some sports
like it's just hard to
break out I mean you're either on a team
or you're an individual and like kind of
who cares after the Olympics and like
it's like a it's a weird dance and I
feel like the sport of snowboarding
skateboarding already had its own
ecosystem where if you're
throwing the javelin or you're doing
something and I I hopefully I don't get
a lot of Javelin coming my way after
this I don't know maybe they do have an
ecosystem that's abundant I have no idea
but I'm just saying that like yeah some
people tend to just go back to their
normal jobs and normal lives right it's
like I I would agree with that if I was
going to say
if there's a curse for the Olympics
um
because I I knew a lot of like highly
competitive platform divers I went to
the University of Miami and even though
I dropped out and failed out I I went
back and I was just kind of homeless
living on the campus of the University
of Miami and uh couch surfing around
there like I befriended the the dive
team yeah it's just an Olympics Factory
and like I would be sleeping on the
floor of the student athlete apartment
that had the number one the number two
or the number three NCAA ranked platform
divers one of which was the senior
National diving champion and um they're
like it was just all about the Olympics
and all but you know like this whole
thing and one of their uh buddies an
older friend
I think it was in Barcelona because it
went Barcelona and then Atlanta I think
so I mean whatever it was maybe it was
Atlanta but this guy won a medal and he
went insane you know like when I'm
saying like
and it was described to me like his
career blew up and everyone knew him or
he just himself no it was just like
where do you go from there yeah oh yeah
you know where do you go from there like
it was described to me that for Olympic
athletes like they've they've trained
it's all they've known it's all the [__]
they've got this one goal this one like
thing and it's about their whole life is
about that and and they'd it's like the
only thing more devastating than not
making it or not winning it's actually
winning yeah because when they hang that
that metal around your neck it was
described to me as like it's imagine
it's like they're hanging the
the end of your life around your neck
this is like they're hanging the
Pinnacle of your achievement and now
it's all downhill from the air in a in a
uh I'm sorry would you say that's kind
of like the feeling you had when you
would go to the red carpets for jackass
movies I said that when I went to the
when I went to the red carpet for the
jackass number two movie I was like man
they were never gonna beat this movie
it's all down here it's like this is as
good as it's ever gonna get and I was
like just like I felt like this red
carpet like represented like you know my
the the and the top and then I'm now I'm
over it like exactly like that you make
such a good point and like in this like
drunken like
like I'm scared like Angry like I pulled
out my wiener and peed all over the red
carpet because I was mad at the Red
Carpet that was like against the
carpet's fault it's a natural thing to
do yes yes
and I did go into a dark thing there
yeah you know I I always kind of
describe it to people that if you can't
relate to it in a certain way like the
most relatable thing would be like Game
of Thrones or something or like Sopranos
is that you're watching some show and
it's been going on for years and you're
what and you're like
it's about to end this is the last
season this is the last episode right
are you thrilled with how the episode
ended are you are you frustrated are you
like look at the hate that came after
Game of Thrones and they're like
you know people
's heads are exploding but but like at
least you say you go to the Olympics and
you you lose you're like well next
season will be better I bet that main
character is going to come back and win
it I bet they're just gonna turn it
around like so you have this identity
that's swept up in it
but when you win you're like well I hit
it and is it everything that I'd hoped
it would be is it everything that people
told me it would be and in many ways it
is in many ways it's not I mean you
probably had more recognition than you'd
had in your life you're not couch
surfing anymore you're you know what I
mean but then again you're like well now
like do I just go find another show and
get attached to another main character
like how do I and you don't want to
you're like well so there's there's this
conflict and then a lot of it is this
like prolonged happiness a delayed
happiness
you know a lot of things that bring
about happiness or fulfillment take a
little time also known as un poco Tiempo
why do I know that because I've been
learning Spanish with this great new
service called Babel and man it can get
you having conversations in a new
language in as little as three weeks and
you know it's like playing a video game
on your phone everybody loves being on
their phones and everybody loves playing
the video games but this is like a video
game that teaches you a whole new
language and that's one of the most
valuable things you can possibly do in
this life plus just like 15 hours of
playing this Babble game learning the
new language it's the equivalent of an
entire semester of a class teaching you
another language in a university plus
with the babble live now you've got
actual live interaction with the
certified foreign language teacher
telling you I love Babel and if you go
to
babble.com that's
b-a-b-b-e-l.com slash Stevo you get 55
off your subscription now do you want to
be a loser for the rest of your life who
only speaks one language I don't that's
why I'm learning a new language on Babel
so one more time go to babble.com Stevo
to enjoy 55 off your subscription what a
deal man jump on it now let's ride this
out no I didn't I didn't I learned a lot
about this later on in life you know
I've done a lot of like work on myself
and talk to people and whatnot but like
you know you realize that you're like
well if I could just do this then I'll
be happy yeah if I could just once I win
the Olympics and I have the recognition
and the success then I'll be happier
I'll be I'll be complete and right at
Zen or whatever you're picturing one
gold medal is too many and it does it's
not enough totally and so uh yeah
exactly
and then you win and you're like well
[__] Michael Phelps got a lot of these
things how do I beat this guy I'm like
he's got more more events than I do how
do I compare how do I show that I'm the
best athlete Olympian ever maybe I'll do
slopes out and a half pipe and I'll do
this and I'll be in a band and I'll you
know what I mean you start like why'd
you think about going into a band oh
yeah oh I did oh yeah I want a guitar to
snowboard contest and I just fell in
love with playing and I was just like it
was just kind of a side thing so if you
in the dock like there was like a fun
project that I'd been you know in a band
with friends and so after the one
Olympics the plan was because you get
the post Olympic Blues you're like what
now like we just talked about the
season's over or the show's over and
you're like now what and so we had
planned to go on tour and that was such
a Saving Grace because I had lost and I
was like well look at these friends I
have look at this life I still have I'm
still good as me without the win or
without people calling for the
appearances and whatever
and so that was like a big kind of
realization in my life is like I didn't
I didn't realize everything until I had
lost you know what I mean which is so
funny to to think about and and when I
talked about I was like I was actually
one of the happiest times of my life
because like the expectation was gone I
was just like kind of settling in this
like well what next and I realized that
like all of my accomplishments from
before weren't erased you know like
we'll forever be able to watch your
films and be like [__] that was a
moment in time and that was so funny and
I'm sure you're doing great you know
that you got this going you got other
things but that was a moment in time and
that doesn't just go away that was
that's embedded in like people's
childhood and that affected them and it
yeah you know I remember cracking you do
with my buddies like did you see that
like I would look forward to it and so
so yeah that that lasts forever you know
and that's so cool but like in your mind
you were like well the [__] it's over I
know dude it's over now what you know
it's hard I'm really glad that Vinnie
brought that up because it was so real
to me like it was so devastating it was
like you know like there's this
just like uh and and I think of it now
and it's like man my life is so much
better now
I'm like running circles around that
Kook that was filming that movie you
know like and uh damn it's just it's
just nuts yeah um so you're the Olympics
that that you lost and and you were you
like officially retired and then you
came out every time so my plan was kind
of to retire I was like three golds in
the pipe like I'm good you know I had
the band going I had things I had you
know a amazing relationship I was in
there's all these things going my way
and I was like okay like let's just hit
it you know I did the like if I could
just win one more then I'll be happy you
know I was doing that a lot with a lot
of things
and so
um
you know after that sorry sparkling
water got me
um so after you officially retired no I
didn't so that was my thing is I was I
was feeling like I was ready to retire
and then I didn't get what I wanted you
know I didn't want to end the season
that way or the the movie or whatever I
was like I gotta but then you know that
feeling of like okay if I could just get
through this I'm gonna retire you're
kind of running that Marathon you see
the finish line and you cross it and
realize you didn't win the marathon
you're looking and there's just another
Marathon like how do I
how do I you know get pumped up to do it
again and so I never told anyone that
that was just kind of in my head
but then um yeah I like dug deep I like
changed a lot of things in my life and
just kind of started plotting the course
to that next Olympics and that was the
2018 yes I I certainly recall that it
was like it felt like a surprise that
you were competing again yeah well
playing music and doing those things
really sends a message that you're over
it so right sponsors people things
everybody kind of went like oh he's off
you know sailing his boat into the
sunset right and and you hadn't won the
Olympics before so it was like oh you
know like it's Sean whites in it you
know like well I usually take the year
after the Olympics off no matter what
just because it's too much to jump back
in I tried that when I was younger and I
just was like left with this like
awful feeling because you know I just I
was like I need time to to chill and so
with the music of those things and so
when I came back people were just kind
of like oh like
does he still got it you know right and
can he perform at these levels and
um yeah there was just like a lot going
on in my world at that time and
I I remember using that as motivation
because I was like well if they don't
think I can do it then perfect I'll try
them I'll show everybody I can you know
what I mean
which was cool but then again for the
old mental well-being like it wasn't a
it wasn't like a happy comeback it was
like I gotta well you know and you're
you're drawing from this pool of you
know uh motivation and some of that had
run dry for that previous Olympics where
I didn't didn't succeed and and so um
and so I was really like put to the test
with this really big crash that I had in
New Zealand what's the difference in
like training time like when you're
going into the Olympics are you training
for like 12 hours a day versus like if
you're doing an event yeah at a local
mountain it's like okay I'm gonna train
a couple hours a day yeah like how
different is that training well it's
changed a lot I mean I would just go
when I was younger and then as you get
older you're like okay well maybe
there's a smarter way to do this and
then it got it boiled down to like hey
I'm good for like two hours is probably
my window I like I show up I warm up I'm
and I'm the best I'm gonna be throughout
the day and then by the second or third
hour I'm starting to you know I'm just
not as sharp I'm getting fatigued and
when you're fatigued and like
I don't know how to describe it if
you're doing that last bench press you
know and your buddy's there to help you
pull the weight so you don't have that
you're like 30 feet up doing whatever
and if you're off it can be detrimental
it can be very very bad and so
um I would just do these power windows
and then I go home and be like well now
what
and so that that became an issue too
because the down time I'm like well now
I'm just here in Switzerland which is
beautiful but there's no like we're off
season this restaurants aren't open
there's no one you know it's not like my
family could come my girlfriend anybody
could be with me so I'm just kind of
like in the doldrums of just waiting for
the wind to pick up and I can go ride
again the next day and you do that for
like a month or two and you're just like
so that's a that's the grind of it you
know keeping the mental because if you
show up you're not motivated to throw
down then why are you even there so you
gotta kind of balance this thing that's
where guitar and other things came into
my world because like well I gotta kill
time somehow yeah right what does
training look like where it's not just
on snowboarding are you doing like
weight lifting are you doing like cardio
yeah I claimed it pretty hard when I was
younger like I I I said that I worked
out but I definitely didn't I was like I
was like dude we're taking the chair
lift I'm going downhill like yeah
no one else at the gym like why would I
and I was winning so it wasn't like I
felt compelled to like get in there and
start pushing some weights around
um at least stretching though I was
stretching a bit I had read an interview
of Andre Agassi that says he doesn't
stretch before he competes so I was like
wow
then I don't need to stretch yeah
neither just I stretch after this is a
thing so yeah because like it's the
whole like you don't want to get your
you know leg or muscles to the breaking
point and get too loose which is why Bob
burn Quest tripped me out because he
would just stretch like crazy right but
and then go skate but um but yeah I
would always just kind of like do a
dynamic warm-up or something to get
warmed up and then go ride and then
stretch Heavy after but yeah I had
physical therapy and and those kind of
things but then around it was after
Sochi I started working out actually on
a regiment and it wasn't to get stronger
it was just because I knew that my
mental Wellness would be better I knew
that after completing a workout I was
happier because I felt like I
accomplished something so I was like
well I should just work out because
it'll make me happier it was everything
was like well what's gonna make me
happier what's gonna make me because the
reasons why I lost weren't physical you
know I mean I had the winning run I felt
like the highest score the night was my
qualifying run and I wanted to do the
easy run you know like it it wasn't that
it was something mental that was keeping
me from succeeding and I wish it was
physical it's way easier to go do a
bunch of sit-ups than to go like fall
back in love with something or someone
or you know what I mean like the thought
of that's really hard and I was like
well how do I start and so I started
picking apart things that just like were
upsetting me I was like how am I being
portrayed on Instagram uh portrayed
excuse me you know like how are people
viewing me on social media how am I
being looked at in these ads do I like
who I'm working with like do I do like
is my manager great is this people good
is this you know I haven't spoken to my
brother in a long time yeah like just
those are the things that I started to
change in my life nothing to do with
snowboarding and then once I came back
to the sport I was just like a happier
guy on the board that's cool and I was
like I mean when I think of Sean White
like
and I think of you as like you know
people describe you as like a robot like
just insane like like this this like
literally like almost just mentally ill
like competitor you know it's just like
got to win like yeah and it makes me
think like that whole drive to just be
the best and I have to win and like
um it I I can't relate to that at all
except when I think about how the
question are you happy
always bothered me so much like if
somebody ever asked me are you happy
like it would just and I couldn't even
put a finger on I just knew I didn't
like it because my my natural thought is
no no I'm not happy like not nothing
like I would I would just was it that
you had to put on the face for the
camera be like yeah I'm so thrilled or
was it it's like just anybody oh just in
general okay setting ask me if I'm happy
and it's like I'll just kind of scan my
my my you know just kind of think about
it and like nothing tells me that I'm
happy and so the question would bother
me it would feel like an invasive it
would just feel rude like how dare you
ask me that like because because the
honest answer is no yeah and and I spent
a lot of time thinking about that and
like why does it bother me so much why
do I feel like I'm not happy and uh and
I come to realize that like there's just
something about me where my default
setting is that like I'm not okay
everything's not gonna be okay like I've
gotta like hurry up I've gotta
frantically scramble and hustle to
strive and to accomplish so that somehow
everything might be okay and it leaves
me
in a Perpetual state of just anxiety and
stress and like constantly feeling like
I've got to do something I've got to
like get something done and that's why
I'm not happy but then the more I think
about it it's like all right well let's
say let's say if I was happy like what
does that mean you know I'm like content
yeah yeah and I'm like dude that sounds
dangerously close to Lazy you know
and I get to the point where like you
know what like I arrived at my final
answer it's like no I'm not happy and I
don't want to be happy because happy is
lazy and if I had a choice between my
like Perpetual Stress and Anxiety or
being happy dude I choose the hustle
yeah but why can't you but why can't you
be happy and hustle at the same time
yeah I mean I just don't like I don't
like can't turn it on but I don't have
to switch yeah that's that's a hard one
to find but that's the goal it's for
sure it's uh you know success without
fulfillment is the greatest failure you
know without enjoying the ride to
getting there and you're just by the
time you get there you're not enjoying
you're like well I got what I wanted but
it's not what I thought I needed and and
there must be more there must be that
next thing and and I've suffered from
that as well for sure I mean you set
these new goals because you're like well
I'm not happy there must be this level
of happiness that I just haven't
achieved yet yeah
um but like the ruthless sort of you
know machine the competitor like that's
for sure a part of me but that's not
like me you know what I mean like it's
what I do like I love it like if you're
getting halfway the goggles come down I
don't like I want I'm out for blood I
want to win you know what I mean and I
was kind of the first to kind of wear
that on my sleeve in a sport that was
like oh we're all here just to have fun
and like right it's sunny out and it's
great and you know I'm like nah dude I
really want to win I'm like I'm working
really hard at this and any other sport
it's like oh yeah
right I love it but for snow
snowboarding was like what a what an ass
you know what I mean and so it was
really strange and I just remember kind
of like navigating these Waters where
I'm like watching the Lakers and the
Celtics play and and and then they're
like should you go out to dinner with
the guys after the comp I'm like I don't
do the Lakers and the Celtics go grab a
beer
there's respect but there's not that you
know and and so and not that that's what
it was like for me I did have like a
cordial you know it wasn't like just
just daggers sending Vibes at the top of
the half pipe it was dude I'm joking
around or having fun or messing with
each other and then the goggles come
down and it's on yeah and like I'm just
intense when it's time to be intense
like if I'm training I'm like I show up
I do my warm-up and I start throwing my
tricks as hard as I can and then I get
the hell out of there but I lived these
two lives so like
by day
you know whatever I was or you know the
the kid that like walked to school I
played handball I like no one cared
about snowboarding in my community but
by night or whatever the superhero come
out and I was like Sean White the like
Prodigy snowboard kid and I had sponsors
that was excitement I was in magazines I
was like so a lot of that grew over time
but I I was able to kind of keep the
separation and so now that I'm older
like I definitely I know that's a big
part of me and and a lot of the TV
programming that you see about me really
harps on that side of things because
it's the ESPN interview like we want to
get right to the bottom of the killer we
want to understand what makes you tick
but there's a rarity that goes into the
other side which is why I was so
thrilled about the dog because you get
to see the family the family road trip
like dude I I had a blast I was doing
all these things but yeah there was that
side of my life that was like you know I
want to succeed I want to prove that my
sport is more than just a fad and I want
to be able to you know hang my hat on
this you know life and career that I
made a change I did something different
and um and so a lot of that kept going
and then like you said like even more
detrimental I actually won my first
Olympics I was 19 and I'm like oh my God
so that's it game game set match like
it's over like okay no this there must
be more and dude not only you just keep
raising the bar but yeah so sorry I
interrupted no please really
I've been working on this but
I'm so excited about this not only did
you win your first Olympics but like you
you won it with like your first run of
like the competition yeah so you get
that first run in and then all of the
competitors follow you and and their
scores come in and nobody matches your
score so then by the time you've done
your SEC second run you've already won
yeah I was at the top they're like and
he won it and they're like all right go
and you have another one Victory lab
yeah go right down the middle of the
half pipe just yeah you don't have to do
anything yeah and then that's when
you're throwing your gnarliest stuff so
for the first Olympics I was just like
oh my God I want you know I did it this
thing and I didn't fully understand the
magnitude of the Olympics you're the
best in the world I thought that yeah I
mean I was like oh this is cool I did it
did Mom Dad prouder but you know what I
mean like USA the team's biggest event I
want it but like my god dude I I came
home and it was just I couldn't walk
around I had huge red hair everyone
spotted me I was walking through like
JFK airport and the whole like terminal
just broke into Applause like an old
movie the slow clap and everyone's
cheering and then I'm courtside at the
next game with you know Regis and like
like yeah and they're like put me on the
Jumbotron I had the metal in my pocket I
hold it up the whole place like Madison
Square Garden goes nuts and like you
know it was just my world had just gone
crazy you know um and if I would have
known that before it would have been a
different game but when we're talking
about the victory laps like that time I
I celebrated I did a big slash on the
wall I did all these things it came down
to the bottom got the got the the award
I was up there Deja Vu man same thing
put in the first run scores come in no
one beat it I won and I'm sitting there
like wow
I'd worked so hard to learn these new
tricks at the time my buddy was like in
a coma trying these crazy tricks and I
was like really weary of this this move
that I invented called the double mic
twist 1260 and I just remember it was
like whispered if I was gonna do it or
not because at the X Games just before
I'd crashed and like hit my face on the
wall my helmet popped off and
um you know it was like is he gonna do
it it's so dangerous what's gonna happen
and I was like I'm gonna I don't know I
just always idolize guys like Mike Tyson
you know he come out in the black shorts
and he'd just knock them out right away
or Muhammad Ali had the gift to gab you
had these guys that had this certain
style about him it wasn't just a win
they had to win in a way and and I was
like I'm gonna I'm going I'm gonna I'm
gonna best this run I'm gonna do this
trick that was really intimidating at
the time and like I'm just gonna let it
all hang out now it could have been I
landed it thankfully but it could have
been replaying it now in my mind I'm
like I could have been the guy with the
gold medal that just was carted off
I don't know why why back to you Susan
it could have been really bad but it
became like a legendary moment where I
like I just stuck it I I did this run I
didn't need to and I just wanted to make
my mark in the sport and that's kind of
like the first Olympics was like oh he
won okay and this was like I gotta
cement in this thing that like this is
what I do this is my life this is
everything and like I got a show where
my level is and and make it make a
lasting impression and that really like
that trick got heard kind of around the
world which was pretty wild yeah insane
when uh I love how like you um
you say that that the whole like machine
and competitor that that gets harped on
and and I I certainly believe that to be
the case
but my
I just have to believe that it's that
same like just
you know attack you know win succeed
mentality like
you can't just have that in snowboarding
you've got to be applying that to
everything you do in your life business
like you know like music like whatever
like the way that you talk about
managing your uh you know like make your
your approval with the photos like
you're like I went through everything
like you're just I just gotta believe
that in every facet of your life you are
highly meticulous strategic and driven
and it's just epic what it it it's I
always say it's one of my best and worst
qualities because I for a long time you
know you develop skills as a child and
you and I got really good at this sort
of like you know try something until you
know fail fail fail until it succeeds
and then and then you know okay well
it's not working how do I how do I
reassess reconfigure everything until it
does work and I just got really good at
that sort of you know um competitive
mindset of like
reset figure it out then when and it
just kept going over and then and then I
got used to this sort of like reward
system of like Well when things get
really hard that must mean that there's
a reward waiting just along the bend
because every time things did get really
hard knee surgery something I come back
and won the gold or like I ripped my
face up and come back and win the you
know what I mean so right every time
things got really hard I kind of got
trained to push through it because
something great was waiting just just in
the future for me
um but I think as I got older the hard
part is that I that was kind of one of
the main skill sets I developed and I
got really good at it but then
you know you go into life and life's not
really like that business isn't like
that I mean in some ways it is but like
you can't win in relationships you can't
you know or if you're going in trying to
win that's a bad way to you don't want
to win right in in the relationship with
your girlfriend or somebody or family
member like I had to kind of learn the
new skill sets at a later stage in life
which was really tough because I was
like oh well what do you mean and like I
couldn't understand why people weren't
as driven as me especially being in a
band or something like that like it's a
collaborative thing that actually
brought a lot of peace to my life
because I remember picking up a guitar
and I was like
I'm like I'm gonna be the best in the
world at this why not I did it with this
I did it I can do it with this and I
remember picking up and I watched some
you know video with Jimi Hendrix and and
Jimmy Page and some amazing guitar
players that's like well that's not
gonna happen all right you know but I
was humbled in that sense of like oh wow
this could be something that's just for
fun you know that I just do and um
and then I remember playing a song it
was a Seven Nation Army by The White
Stripes and it was like one string said
and I was like I was like it's so simple
like I always thought music was so
complex it had to be so easy yeah you're
just conveying to match some of the best
songs in the world are so simple right
and so that really brought like some
peace to my life in that way but yeah it
was a weird sort of switch that had to
happen for me to kind of like realize
um you know other other avenues and
skill sets in life because it it's a
very motivating thing it gets a lot done
but it doesn't really give you that
completed sort of life you're looking
for you know right yeah so so what's
life like now like these days where are
you at man it's great
um and I can say that truthfully it's
it's it's weird I look back and now
having the documentary come out it feels
like I was able to kind of put a nice
ribbon on all of this stuff and look it
back at the career and go oh this this
was great there's a moment yeah look at
the story it's not the whole story
obviously how can you fit
you know over 20 something year career
in a couple hours but you know it was
when you do have a docu series like this
and yeah and having the the career that
you've had all the achievements that
you've done do you look back at some
like a project look at this and say I
wish I could have done that differently
or I regret doing this or anything like
that or do you get emotional oh my god
dude watching the edits was like
agonizing yeah it was so hard just
because I'm like I'm watching the
interview where I say this and I'm like
you're lying like I could just see it I
was like it's wearing on you and you're
putting up this front or like I'd watch
myself just like turn the most like
awful situation into this positive thing
and like I would just find the
positivity out of nowhere like well I
got hit in the face and like look I just
like now I know I can take that hit so
look it's great what are you talking
about right and so you kind of see these
weird patterns and things but yeah it's
hard still it's like I said it's a part
of me it's hard to look at that
competition and sojinko oh my God I
could see so clearly like why couldn't I
have done this or why wouldn't I have
maybe if I would have signed that deal I
wouldn't have gone there and done this
like it's so hard to watch it and I'm
such a visual sort of feelings like I
see it and I feel it and I make it
happen and and to watching is like
agonizing because it's it's just me in
that place all over again you know what
I mean I feel exactly how I felt in that
moment so it's hard for me to separate
it so I would go through like a few days
of like
being kind of down and out when I watch
some of the edits even though there are
these amazing moments like especially
the last Olympic run because I'm like
God
I would have just stepped on the gas a
little here like I clipped the top on
that last round good to finish it like
you know and you you're humbled in the
sense because you're gonna like well it
is what it was you know and if you can
just
sit back as a viewer and watch it's a
really great series it's really
enjoyable you know but like when I was
watching it I'm like well they forgot
that
you know when I crashed the Lamborghini
I got another one they didn't even talk
about it you know whatever stupid stuff
you're like they'd even say that I did
this or like my that one edit didn't
even make it in and like you're watching
it from this perspective of like trying
to get your whole life in this thing and
really replicate that moment in time and
and so it was a really tough experience
I'm thrilled it's over with but but yeah
I mean to answer earlier like I mean my
days today are just like I'm still just
as active I skate i surf snowboard
um launched a company with my brother
called White space which is really fun
we're making outerwear activewear and
snowboards goggles all this stuff and
now we're out looking for our team
because when I was a kid I was sponsored
by Burton and they helped give me
product and like gave me travel budget
and like the stuff and so now we're like
looking at is so awesome like I I was
getting off a chair lift and this little
girl got off the chair with one of my
boards
um do my heart saying I was like oh my
God I had not seen one of my Boards out
in the wild before and I like go up like
hey what's up I was like I gotta say you
can't tell why I'm all blacked out with
the goggles the helmet and she's like
what's up I was like I really like
you're born she's like yeah thanks you
know she was so cool and I'm like I was
like well can I get a high five you know
she's like yeah sure you know but but
it's so sick to kind of see that next
generation and and you know I know what
my first snowboard meant to me and to
see somebody that age with my board and
and building the team so that's giving
me a lot of enjoyment of like being in
the sport but not having to throw myself
yeah you know that's good the big tricks
and then um and then yeah it's been it's
been really interesting you know I I
talked to a lot of athletes they're like
don't stop working out right so like the
comeback's really hard so sure so I'm
still really active doing those things
and then um yeah it's wild I'm curious
is snowboarding it's got to be like like
we look at what's going on with
skateboarding and it's the 12 year olds
that are doing 1080s I mean these kids
are coming out and like like I don't
know how old this this like these little
girls are that are like just destroying
on bird ramps and the kids on the mega
ramps so
are this like isn't snowboarding like
the gnarliest things are happening with
like 12 year old kids now yeah for sure
I mean I wouldn't say like the top
tricks like skateboarding you're like oh
my God like a lot of top Pros aren't
doing those tricks and this is right 10
year old just showed up and crushed
everyone like that's not really
happening but tricks that like
I I couldn't fathom doing as an adult
these kids are doing that like I created
way back when but they're just like oh
yeah they got that one now and they're
trying this and they're working toward
the bigger tricks so yeah like I think
the swell has come you know
definitely like heavier in that younger
generation and like you said the women's
Department yeah crushing and so you see
a lot more you know female Riders and
and skateboarders and it's really cool
to see and and and I feel like there was
such a big gap in the tricks first for
men's and women's and it's really like
closing now wow a lot of the younger
female snowboarders are are crushing and
they're trying the big tricks and
they're going huge and they're doing it
all and it's it's rad to see that that
like that sort of um part of the sport
is growing dramatically yeah
that's epic man yeah yeah they have the
um in Encinitas
behind uh What uh Hansen's there there
was always this like snowboard oh that
carpet thing yeah it's like a carpet
like treadmill
snowboard training I don't know what
that thing was I was dying to know if
you ever caught on it I remember seeing
it as a kid and being like what in the
hell is this thing and like I think it
was for people to like try out their
skis it was basically like a it was like
a big treadmill with white carpet on it
and you and they would turn it on and
you'd kind of like
like make your turns on it but no I
don't I never messed with that thing no
it was and then there's like uh like
what other like artificial like you know
like like Dubai's got one of the biggest
indoor parks now I mean that's just
artificial snow Yeah they have these
indoor facilities and so during covet it
was kind of wild I was like oh I can't
fly to New Zealand where I'd normally
train the borders are all shut I can't
get into Canada I can't I was I was like
huh
I wonder if I could go to Dubai you know
like maybe they'd let me in and so we
actually sent them renderings and got
the schematics of the plus I was like
that would be the most James Bond move
of me to be they're like where is he oh
he's down in Dubai like training wait
Sean's in the desert snowboarding like
what you know and so it actually we had
it all ready to go but the weight of the
half pipe and the machine that makes a
half pipe wouldn't be supported by the
structure down there so we got that
close to doing it right
um but um but yeah there's some pretty
amazing things like that I know people
people in London and other places are
they've got these things called the dry
slopes yeah so it's kind of similar to
what you saw but it's more like bristly
material and they they're building these
big jumps and things and so places in
China I mean China is exploding with the
sport because obviously with the
Olympics and the excitement and and
um
yeah the culture's like really taking on
the sport and so you see a lot of people
um
you know coming out of there with these
big big new tricks and while you know
inventions to be snowboarding year round
which is really kind of wild to see but
yeah it's getting exciting and and
um I don't know I'm thrilled to see
where the Sport's kind of gonna go from
here you know it's a trip how about like
commentating for the X Games and the
Olympics are you into that or I don't
know I mean I've been asked to do it for
the Olympics and I was like yeah okay
that that makes sense for me I'd love to
be part of that you know
um just because I know what it's like to
be standing up there it's your first
time you're wearing clothes that you
don't wear normally wearing a gloves
that you know like you kind of shed your
identity when you get there you become
part of Team USA everybody's wearing the
same thing in a sport that's very
individual it's like my music my style
this is the tricks I do whatever you
become part of this big Team all of a
sudden you've never felt that before so
it's a weird experience
um but yeah so like for the for the
Olympics I definitely would love to do
that I don't know I mean I feel feel
like the everyday event I don't I don't
know it's something where
wanna maybe it's me the competitiveness
I'm like I'd have to be the best at it
you know that'd be so good and they're
like oh my God come on we got to get him
on the mic you know
um so there's that factor but um but
yeah I don't know I kind of feel like
something's gonna grab hold and it's
kind of like obviously the company's
amazing it gives me that kind of it
scratches that itch of being in the
sport but not really you know but I
don't know there's something kind of I
don't know I feel like we'll catch my
interest and and just like shoot me up
in it you know are you doing music Still
I just played for fun yeah I think that
was something that like it's kind of
like speaking a language in a way like
you meet people like oh well what guitar
do you play like oh what style and like
oh what pic awareness whatever your
questions you have but like you kind of
can jam together and you so I've always
loved music in that fashion but I don't
know I remember talking to some friends
that
um played music because the the hard
part about music is It's a Grind man I
mean I thought I traveled but then you
go on the road with musicians and it's
that Groundhog Day I'm just like oh what
city are we in cool wake up going to the
Green Room try to get some coffee or
whatever uh be ready for sound check
then it's like you got a few hours to go
do whatever and then the show starts and
so you got to get ready you play the
show everybody wants to party with you
after and then by 2 A.M the bus loads up
off to the next city and you're just
doing that day after day after day oh we
know about it
so yeah it's It's a Grind it's like it's
a whole thing and then the radio shows
and things so like you know I think
playing music really kind of opened my
eyes to yeah there is that image of the
rock star jet setting and playing the
huge venue and get back on the plane or
your metallic or whatever and use one of
these huge bands but um for the average
musician Like It's a Grind yeah it's a
thing and so
um so I don't know I I definitely like I
love music but I don't know if I would I
would want to dip back in in the way
that I did before you know
um where are you spending unless I had a
van I could take around yeah
I mean is it is it true that uh like
every Olympic person that I met has that
the Rings tattooed somewhere on them oh
yeah yeah I know I know a few that have
I don't know it's not like a thing that
you made it yeah I always thought that
like they they would yeah I remember
thinking about doing it
that's the thing it's like it's like
Rocky like he doesn't even win in the
first movie It's The Thrill of the fight
it's like what it took to get there when
you become an Olympian like you're part
of History it's that's the big stage you
know so winning and getting the medals
is for sure the icing on the cake and
what everybody wants but just to go is
like insane you you join history and so
you kind of learn a lot about that when
you go and so um so I see a lot of
people that like they're so proud they
get their Rings
you have a few yeah you opted out for
the reason yeah yeah it's so funny like
they're trademarked so yeah yeah I'd
have to get approval of it
even the Olympic rings tattooed Army
like oh no way dude you're an Olympic
medalist like oh no I was just in the
Olympics but yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I
went to Sochi oh I was there bro no I
just went and checked it out
for sure and you put it on your neck huh
interesting
where do you spend most of your time
these days you know I bounce around a
ton that was my thing is after the
Olympics I told my girlfriend I was like
let's just go let's go do the stuff that
I didn't have the time to do or like if
I was normally supposed to be in in some
icy cold place you know training let's
go to the beach somewhere and do
something sick or let's surf so yeah I
love surfing so I was named Sean after
Sean Thompson uh okay Pro South African
Surfer uh dad loves surfing and so um so
yeah I try to I try to get waves where I
can but we went on this like tour I mean
we we basically Costa Rica we went to
Cabo to Antarctica to Indonesia to
Switzerland Maldives Dubai I mean we we
just kind of just been going all over
and checking these things off the list
it's been so much fun so how did you get
to Antarctica did you go by plane or did
you do the uh the route by ship man it
was it was such an insane trip we got
really spoiled our buddy
um you know we ended up taking his plane
down to like the southernmost of
children Chile yeah well we were in
Argentina and then to Chile because you
got to wait for the weather pattern to
you know cause it's a special plane to
get there right so yeah we got off that
and got on the special plane to get to
Antarctica and there's nothing down
there there's no town There's it's just
science research facilities right you
know and so it's like being on Mars yeah
and I never wanted to go there or
thought to go there but when this came
up and I was like oh my God we got to do
this and so from there we got on this
bow and then the boat takes you around
and you like go on excursions to see
whales and Penguins and and the crazy
part was is that the ship we were on had
a helicopter and they're like
well do you want to go snowboard I was
like [__] yeah so we ended up like you
know and and of course I'm like the
luckiest dude ever it snowed the night
before we were gonna go ride and we got
this amazing like powder day in
Antarctica it was like once in a
lifetime sort of thing because I asked
the guy was like what is what's the snow
like he's like it's pretty hard pack
it's not great you know it's more just
to say you did it but we lucked out I
had this like really fun day on the
mountain and you like come riding down
to the bottom and there's just like
penguins and [__] on the beach and like
yeah there's if you check out um my
Instagram just Sean White
um I got some pretty fun videos because
uh
Lewis Hamilton the F1 driver became a
friend and he came on the trip as well
and you talk about the competitive
mindset and the mentality like he
watched me do this long sort of pond
skim this like Frozen like just the
water's so cold down there and he
watched me like skim over this thing
he's like I gotta do it so he went down
and he tried it and fully ended up
sinking in the middle of this thing he's
like
anybody normally at that point would
leave and he's like I'm doing I'm gonna
be like frozen he's like
like walking back up gets to the top
does it again and Nails it you know so
you kind of see
um you know some fun stuff but that trip
was yeah it was nuts yeah well I'm
always curious what percent of the
population has been to Antarctica yeah
it's gotta be less than one percent
nobody can say they've been to all seven
continents yeah I mean nobody I know
except for you that yeah Steve Wozniak
yeah we've been uh we've been dying to
do that man oh yeah do it do it yeah
it's it's a special place and the Sun
never really goes down it just kind of
it just turns into this beautiful sunset
and this it just keeps going and you're
like I just really she's still giving
her this the colors and then all of a
sudden it just turns into this epic
Sunrise it just never gets dark yeah and
then the other part of the year just
never a good sunlight yeah yeah that's
you know how many times have you seen
the Northern Lights
I think only like once but it was faint
that's something I actually want to go
back and check out but I did I did go
surfing in like the Arctic Circle up
there
um and I was I was very young just to
say I did it my my wetsuit had a big
hole in it it was like a hand-me-down
and it was freezing but I you know
Instagram man there we go check me out
yeah dude
um I will check that everybody follows
Sean White on Instagram how do you find
them Shawn White Sean White
yeah easy
yeah dude man what how rad I feel like
we should we should cut you lose but
this has been so epic dude yeah man the
uh are you happy yeah yeah I can truly
say I'm I'm good yeah you know what I
don't think I'm not gonna go as far as
to say I'm happy I'm gonna say my life
is really good piece of [__] yeah yeah
yeah yeah
my my life is really good like I'm I'm
uh
I'm stoked on how much stuff is going on
how much I'm working on and I just want
to keep working on it and make it
brighter yeah yeah I think for me the
the realization that like I can be good
right now and still go for these things
was the huge weight lifter right where
I'm like oh I can be thrilled because I
thought I was a weakness before I'm like
oh if I say like you said it's laziness
if I say that I'm good then then how am
I going to motivate to go get this thing
that I think will make me happy man and
and I realized I was like well wait if I
can just be happy right now and like
appreciate what I have and enjoy this
process now I'm enjoying it and I'm I'm
even more motivated because I'm having
fun doing it you know yeah the the guy
who wrote Think and Grow Rich Napoleon
Hill interviewed like hundreds of
billionaires back in the 1900s okay and
he said like the one thing that he saw
that they had there there are or a lot
of them because they had all the money
in the world to do whatever they wanted
and he said
almost all of them didn't have peace of
mind so he's like the goal of these
people were to get peace of mind and
none of them ever had that so yeah but
that's why they were well because they
hadn't done it because they had they had
so much money yeah no no but they had so
much money that that towards the end of
their life they didn't know how to get
rid of the money that wouldn't curse the
next person oh that's why they started
doing libraries in universities in
Carnegie Hall yeah because they were
like there's no way I'm going to give
this money to my kids because it's such
a burden to like have that much
responsibility that they practically
people said money ruins lives families
yeah she was so worried about it I mean
that's the whole thing like you you
don't want to deprive like you know for
me to win that contest and like buy my
first car like buy my first house I was
like those are huge if you're just
handed that from your parent you're like
oh well you see what happens you know
you don't like what where's that
excitement to strive for something to
earn something and feel that
accomplishment in life you know it took
those those horrible crashes and lessons
and those things and falling out with
people all these things to you know get
to where I'm at today to be you know in
a in a good peace of mind and all that
so that's what's hard is like watching
the dog you're like [__] I would love to
go back and change things but hey you
know God if I would never have lost that
thing I never found right this Gem and
and it's brought me a lot of contentment
in life so it's kind of hard to like you
know Factor all that in when you're
watching and going through it everybody
watch the last run on Max you gotta
watch it is it the same is that where uh
Tony Hawk's documentary is I want to say
yeah I mean I think he launched HBO and
then it got folded in right so yeah but
but similar was that a crazy one man
yeah I mean he mentioned to me I hope
I'm allowed to share this
um that he he wasn't as involved you
know yeah he was like look you know do
you do your thing I mean because it's a
tough thing to do it's really weird you
know you got very very
uh vulnerable
I don't know the the Tony Hawk's dog
Community could have been so so
vulnerable and so uh exposed if he was
really involved so I think that that
that that documentary probably benefited
a great deal for me yeah there was a
certain point where I just cut it off
too I was like look like I I just wanted
to make sure I'm like the trick name's
got to be right you can't be showing me
surfing this wave and all of a sudden
I'm on a different way of going the
other way you know there's probably
edits I was like it's got to be right
and so I weighed in on a lot of that
stuff and then I just left him with like
a hay
you know the fact that I you know I gave
him like three or four things it's like
this person was really important he
should have a bigger role we talked
about Jake Burton the owner of Burton
Snowboards and kind of the father of you
know snowboarding and and I was like
he's got to be in there we got to really
touch on the skateboarding career a bit
more because that was such a huge part
of my life and career and then you know
a few other things and I was like but
and I'm done so when I watched it when
it came out was actually the first time
I really watched yeah the whole thing
and I was pretty hyped that they did
such a great job so it's epic man yeah
so yeah and back country is the name of
the the companies all right uh uh back
country is a distributor for our our
outerwear for that on your Instagram oh
yeah yeah so they make all the clothes
and stuff for us and help us distribute
and market and all that stuff but then
the snowboards is kind of on our own it
was a way to like go like I know
snowboards in and out like I want to
make sure that these boards like ride
perfect and the edges are great and the
materials and like so I basically took
my Olympic board and like broke it into
three different models nice one for
powder one for Park and like half pipe
and all terrain and then and then we
worked with this company to help develop
uh the outerwear you know all the
jackets and all the gear you wear but
that's where you can go get get the gear
but it's called White space yeah all
right white space yeah Sean White on
Instagram the last run on Max yeah we go
over to my house and escaped my I would
love to what happened I love you hit me
up I got time I'm retired man
super fun
there you have it ladies and gentlemen
my new Bro Sean White I mean how rad is
that I'm gonna invite him over to escape
my huge ramp in the backyard
um we'll see it's really A rad skater
and his show on Max the last run is
really rad too I genuinely recommend
everybody watching and I'm genuinely
grateful to everybody who stuck around
to the very end you know I love you my
beautiful street team thank you always
and uh what what can I say what's going
on going back on tour this uh this week
or next week I leave for for the the
final shows of The Bucket List tour
um I talked about I bought the property
and we got 44 Acres
so epic I love you guys thanks so much
that's it